how's it going right - beautiful welcome
back to another episode of a place I
don't actually read them hot hello I
[Applause]
guess people like their privacy when
they pee lesson learned
whoa whoa what is for this noise oh come
on of course no way he is just doing his
daily routine of having swag yes
we're just looking for that that that's
that bad that thing and that's all we
want we want want no trouble now do we
all right bathroom pretty sure they
don't put day love it it's in the
kitchen why of course is that batteries
battery I can't carry any more batteries
all right batteries in and then and then
in it ah [ __ ]
well well it's with this noise shut up
game alright it means we have to pass
Pappa Pappa pills here and some fella
hi yo stome hey shut your mouth
they're so not invited to my party of
cool people all right Jess it's you I
never been so happy to see a dead car
there's nothing okay
hello picked up the key to the third
floor girls all right where are we where
black me I don't know I don't want to
investigate here father
we are going back hey hey I'm sorry I
didn't mean to hurt your feelings
you can't come to my party hi did you
not hear me this is the ones in the next
epidemic gotta bottom boom all right
we're fine we're fine she's just gonna
go up just gonna go up
see you can't find this goodbye y'all to
the hole to Dubrow
all right where were they bad flood
ah yes quite splendid and that's how
it's done make sure nobody's followers
if you know what I mean up five no okay
fine all right
ah as a wise man once said don't wear
tampons if you're a boy there we go
follow the blood huh but I'm too awesome
no matter it fails well don't mind if I
do
they're [ __ ] everywhere wait follow
the blot mom geez get out of my game all
right
huh and oh yeah hey hey hey Martin get
it get it
there's the dirt snow with the Tompa
started back but dead Matt de Luna
needed off a helmet vectors in W I am
none left tire all right hey
[Applause]
I had a bad day already
what the [ __ ] alright then I'm cool it's
cool hey ji you don't have here okay
what chest don't speak maybe I'm going
crazy too
what is that oh this says okay I can
climb no big deal
oh oh can I'm like a man man ever again
fun alright
oh we're back okay they just wanted to
remind us that there's ghosts
no biggie haha I can't believe I missed
that all right now cut yes thank you
blood thank you
where are the [ __ ] at the club though
I know there's a female ward I have yet
to see cherries in this game I've seen
ding dongs game don't test me
don't test me can't the dead judge
anymore I'm gonna make this rats pay for
what they did okay
and the ghosts I will call the
Ghostbusters on you [ __ ]
okay I'm a neigh neigh neigh neigh men
okay so he went over there that means
I'm going over here
nice hey hey don't run out of battery
now so dark think about this game with
the oculus rift I would literally cry
every time I hope they come out with
like a custom story edition oh baby
custom story edition some people can
like modern [ __ ] and make it with oculus
and make it like with that oh come on
it's naked couple how am I supposed to
do that
[Music]
oh hell no sit down so I know to cry cry
a lot
[Music]
did we actually make
can this sound chill out a little bit
please thank you no no it's our blood I
don't see any blood oh geez all right
time to test my parkour skills I just
don't want to fall down I can't climb up
okay we're okay we're fine we're fine
it's all good in the hood good in the
hood and the bread yo oh no no no no no
I'm already falling no oh the evidence
oh my thyroid level probe oh oh oh get
up get up and get up get up
justice plan
exact except the opposite gosh [ __ ]
are you are you kidding me
go back with it you need your camcorder
to navigate in the darkness
oh so we have to go back well good cuz I
was hoping that would happen all right
it went down here somewhere hello oh
okay I don't know why you guys hate me
I'm so tolerant to gay couples I think
it's actually kind of cute
you know if they found love even though
even though they have difficulties so I
don't understand
I really don't
someone peeing all right it's not a big
deal that's all good in the head except
we are not in the hood sorry okay
maybe it landed in a toilet that late no
it's potato sack all right all right
Tamra where are you a lady he and like
my mom I always say frame hey ain't name
whoa whoa Wallace I'm high I don't see
nothing all righty then
you're not comprender let us be honest I
hate y'all you're so ugly [ __ ] you yeah
you smell weird [ __ ] i sighs genitals
from undernea ah why do they do that
you're never gonna leave this place what
are these bottles are you beautiful face
you want to kiss you want to kiss come
on come on your mandalas smooch
hey hey it's not gay if no one is
watching come here ha ha ha you are
gonna do it ha gay and i'm skidding
nothing wrong nothing wrong at all I
like it it's cute it's adorable
ok why are we doing my Ducks are just
sinking lower and lower they're more I'm
less progressing that was not even a
sentence I think okay see what I'm
talking about
it's pretty Larkin shut up darkness I'm
busy being scared oh wait hey what what
why can I just grab it you have to go
around or something oh okay I have to go
run okay all right what have we got here
I know it has a little scratch all right
all right
survival instincts activated close the
door
[ __ ] yeah you ain't getting me today not
today Russ what the [ __ ] is happening oh
[ __ ] okay yes nope
yes
ah che Oh Oh can we climb up we can't
climb up my god we're actually gonna do
it ah okay got a header all on my face
why are you there
all right let me love this [ __ ] alright
you need a chill you know if this if
this footage I'll come home everything
is fine and then I gotta check the
footage and it got corrupted like yeah
well honestly I think there's enough
evidence for any police officers all
right she just I don't know what I'm
talking about but I'm going in here so
that's cool
all right how do we get up there like
this nail Bank don't drop your camera
sorry okay you need to get up that ledge
thank you all right muck ding let's see
that don't forget his name and sub
constantly Naveen Martin I don't know
yellow okay
tops and out lapels well it ain't easy
once your yellow you all are you always
home
see how I'm talking about I do this
every day except on Wednesdays I break
some ways okay I regret that job but are
not for long I regret that jump Tara and
now I just feel like an idiot
alright we can get up here alright hey
hi friend you you're watching me but you
don't have any eyes alright
I don't record it for an hour now I'm
sick of this is one way up only one way
uh-huh
tell me all about it where is it oh you
have an eye well excuse me sir well you
are pretty look at those teeth you could
get any girl you like any girl and don't
let anybody tell you different how
because I'm wearing fancy as clothes
right I haven't technically seen my own
face I sense a plot twist actually they
kind of gave it away to us
okay anyway let's not think of this
sorry too much let's focus on our
objective let's just find him because
escaping would just be too easy
I saw where is he
it's not even on the thing I guess it's
on the chapel all right sure telling off
[ __ ] me I can't deal with this anymore I
can't deal with this anymore I'm a bunny
I'm a cute little bunny I'm a cute bunny
I like you buddy
how about you buddy alright Prez
this is a pencil I hope you enjoyed this
episode leave a like if you did as
always I'd really appreciate it it makes
me feel like hey you're actually there
watching that's awesome anyway hit
subscribe to come over today and I'll
see you
[Music]